[Music]
are you calling somebody what if they
answer
hey
i'm in ghana watching two romance
scammers at work
he calls himself the punisher and she is
miami queen
yeah
i missed you
and to my surprise
they're scamming men not women
[Music]
how long has it been baby in the world
right yeah i know
but i told you i had problems with my
friends
sweetheart let me go and take a shower
okay i'll call you when i'm done yeah
don't go anywhere just wait for me
and we're done
so what just happened here you were
started to call somebody or right
and then when he accepts what if it's a
video you pass it on to her yeah when
you're communicating he thinks he's
communicating the whole time with her
yeah he's communicating with you mm-hmm
and then you're just mine is just to
look beautiful and make him feel
sweet
how much i love him
most of romance scamming is messaging
just typing but they've rented the space
tonight for these occasional video calls
hoping to satisfy their clients
how many people do you guys know that
are scammers a whole lot of people you
have we have we have friends
like dozens hundreds of thousands all
your friends are doing it yeah i have
friends who are rich very rich they
build houses big big cars
everybody's making money
wiring money gift cards or straight up
cash are preferred
but payment in bitcoin is also becoming
popular
i'm a female
i'm using the profile of a female so
you're pretending to be a woman and
scamming i'm pretending to be a human
it's easier to get money from men he
says
and they're simply more men using online
dating sites
[Music]
and yet
back in the states
far fewer men than women
report being victims
and this person you're talking to
michael has no idea that you're actually
a man in ghana yes
i started falling in love with him
not for intercourse or whatever it is
but
you know
i i thought for him right
my gear is the kind hearthstone i think
michael has been too good to me
how much money has michael sent you so
far what i'm thinking more than ten
thousand dollars for what
what do you say line 10 apartments
school fees michael know some school
year in ghana
wow okay so
i do this
are you actually calling him
yes where is he virginia
so michael is not online
oh okay no dice
but had michael picked up he would have
seen this video recording of a young
woman this video will play and you
answer the call
but if you talk it doesn't match she's
not talking you see she's typing
oh my god wow so you have the video and
then you're just typing yes where did
you get this video you buy it online oh
you buy it yeah
like scripts these videos are part of a
scammer's professional toolkit
an underground industry unto itself
i missed
[Music]
[Music]